(man) the sharks are back,and they're looking for
the best productsand Businesses
America has to offer.
The only thing that really
matters--what is it? Money.
If the sharks heara great idea,
they're ready to invest,using their own money...
I think you're smart, slick,
greedy, and it's offensive.
And fight each otherfor a piece of the action.
I'll go halves with you,
but no Robert.
I hate being screwed
on these deals.
It's nothing personal,
Robert.
No, it is personal,
cuban.
Okay, it is,
but I don't care.
But first, the entrepreneursmust convince a shark
to invest the full amountthey're asking for,
or they'll walk awaywith Nothing.
This is a $100--
$500 million company.
It's sink...
that's almost an insult.
Or Swim.
5% feels offensive to me.
Would you have taken
5% for facebook?
Well Put.
Who are the sharks?
They're five self-made,filthy rich Investors.
Kevin O'Leary isa venture capitalist
who started a software businessin his basement,
which he eventually soldfor $3.2 Billion.
Barbara Corcoranturned a $1,000 loan
into a real estate Empireworth hundreds of millions
in the shark-filled cityof Manhattan.
Daymond John isa fashion and branding expert
Who grew his homemade hatsand t-shirts
into the globally recognizedfashion brand Fubu.
Robert herjavec,
the son ofan immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
Who sold his firstinternet companies
for over $350 million.
And mark cuban, a self-made,billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the 2011 NBA ChampionDallas Mavericks.
First into the tankis Dave Mayer,
with a new twistto a conventional product.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Dave Mayer,
and my company is
clean bottle.
I'm here today
seeking $60,000
in exchange for 5%
of the company.
Like pretty much everyone
these days,
I use a water bottle.
And they're great.
You don't have to spend
a fortune on bottled water,
and it's just the right thing
to do for the environment.
But these bottles all have
one major problem--
you can't get to the bottom
of them to clean them out.
So every two weeks
that go by,
I'd open my bottle,
and it looked like
a science experiment
gone wrong.
It's full of mold,
it smelled disgusting.
The last thing I wanna do
is drink out of this thing.
So one day, it hit me.
And that's when I came up
with the clean bottle.
It's the world's Only bottle
that unscrews from the bottom
as well as the top.
So you can get in there,
clean it out,
air-dry it so it doesn't
get nasty in the first place,
and the nozzle comes out,
so you can clean that out,
as well.
So I launched the product
about a year ago.
And I didn't have a lot
of money to market it,
so I had to get creative.
I went to the biggest
bike race in the world.
Check out what I did.
(man) and if you lookto the side there,
you'll see a giant bottlerunning alongside... (sharks laughing)
Oh.
That's fantastic!
That thingis literally everywhere.
I mean, this guymust be exhausted.
(laughter)
Look at him wavingto the fans now--poor Fellow.
That is great.
Talk about
guerilla marketing.
Let me show you
the running Holder.
I know you ran
the New York marathon.
A lot of people
run with water, as you know.
(Robert) This is
a very clever Idea.
Thank you.
You got any sales?
I launched the product
in may,
right before
the Tour de France.
Right.
Since then, I've sold
$750,000 worth of bottles.
How many units is that, Dave?
It's about 150,000 units.
(laughs)
We're in every single
retailer that matters.
It's so simple.
It's one of those ideas
that--when you showed it to me,
my first thought was--
of course.
Why didn't all the bottles
start this way?
Your, uh, mascot looks like
he's about 7-foot-18.
(mark laughs)
You guys should meet him.
I am the clean bottle boy!
Ride Clean or die!
Are you kidding me?
Oh! My God!
(mark laughs)
Champions ride Clean.
Losers--they ride dirty.
Who is that?
Bill Walton's, like, one of
the all-time greatest centers
in NBA history.
How would you get
a superstar like this?
I saw him at a--
at a basketball game,
and I knew that he
was a cyclist.
And you just went up to him?
I went up to him.
You know, nothing ventured,
nothing gained.
Bill, are you part
of this deal in some way,
other than appearing here today?
No. I'm just a fan,
and I'm a user
and I'm a believer.
Dave, tell us
the economics, okay?
You've sold $750,000.
150,000 units.
That's 5 bucks a pop, right?
That's right.
Did you make any money
on the $750,000?
In the last 12 months,
we made $118,000.
Why aren't you just
investing that
so you don't need
$60,000,
you keep your 5% equity?
$118,000--we're using
a lot of that money.
We're about to take out
the tools
for the stainless steel
Bottle.
That's $68,000.
I need to eat. I have a--
I have a family, two kids,
and I want
strategic investors.
Dave, you under--you
understand my skepticism?
Great--great Presentation.
Love the tall guy...
I am the clean bottle boy!
Throw it down, big man!
Throw it down!
But it's $60,000!
You're asking for $60,000.
(daymond) For 5%!
You're here to make
one of us work for you,
because you're
only offering us 5%.
You know, I'm--I'm greedy
just like you guys.
I don't wanna give away
two arms--cut off two arms
when you only have
to cut off one Pinkie.
$60,000 is 5%.
I'm willing to negotiate.
If you guys wanna
go up more,
if you believe in the product,
you believe in the vision,
then we can have
that conversation.
So, Dave, here's what
I think about you--
I think you're smart,
you're slick,
you're greedy,
and it's offensive...
and I can't wait to be
your friend and partner.
All right. Thanks.
Right?
But it has to be worth it
for me.
Now you're offering,
for $60,000, 5%.
But I would want 25%.
Okay.
So I've worked at Goldman Sachs
for two years.
All I did was valuation.
That's just
the wrong outcome for me.
I mean, $60,000 for 25%?
Is that what you said?
You know what? You know why?
So $240,000 is how
you're valuing the company?
I'm not valuing the Company.
Okay.
I'm valuing my time.
5% is not enough
for me to get out of bed.
How much would it take?
25%.
Okay.
Are there any other offers?
I'll give you $100,000
for zero equity
and 50 cents of every bottle
you sell in perpetuity.
I respect your offer,
but I think
to siphon off cash
at a time when
we're growing the quickest,
I don't think you would advise
anyone to do that deal.
What you need is capital
to buy inventory.
I'm here not just
for the money.
God's honest truth--
I'm here for you guys.
It's advice. It's getting
on the phone once a month.
Let's have some coffee.
Let's talk.
You know what is such
a turn-off for me in this deal?
5%. It feels offensive to me.
Would you have taken
5% for facebook?
So don't discount that.
Well put.
So, Dave, I'm not offended
by the low percentage ask,
'cause you're not asking
for a lot of money.
I think you were dead on
when you valuated Kevin's offer.
He's taking cash flow
out of a business,
which is like sucking blood
out of a business
when it's starting out.
I think that's what you do
when you take equity.
You know you can't do that.
You're stealing his company.
Kevin. Daymond is valuing
your entire company
at $240,000--
I'm valuing my time.
Now, I can--I can
change the offer
if you and I
don't have to speak
and it's just
an investment.
That's so disrespectful.
I mean, the guy's a nice guy.
Why wouldn't you help
the guy out if you can?
It's not about helping.
It's about time.
Here's my offer--
$60,000 for 10%.
Okay.
Mark?
I'll give you $60,000
for 8%,
because I see the vision
and I see where you can go,
and I think it's gonna
be worth a lot of money.
Final offers, everyone?
All the offers are in?
I'll give you $60,000
for 5%.
Your original ask.
I mean, I don't own
a basketball team,
but I have a lot of connections
in the sports world.
I spent last weekend biking
with Lance Armstrong
and Steven Bauer.
I'm happy to take 5%.
It's a bit of a flier.
I'll give you the $60,000--
exactly what you asked for.
Dave, you know,
I think you have two
very good offers on the table,
so I'm gonna retract
my offer. I'm out.
And just to clear the deck,
this just isn't
my type of business.
I'm out.
Dave, time for you
to make a decision.
What do you want to do?
♪♪♪
David Has three offerson the table.
Kevin is offering $100,000for no equity,
but wants a royaltyof 50 cents per bottle Sold.
Mark is offering $60,000for 8%
and Robert is asking$60,000 for 5%.
So I offered you
exactly what you asked for.
Yeah.
What do you say?
(sighs)
mark...
I know it's a big ask...
$60,000 for 6%.
That's a $1 million valuation.
We've almost done that
in 15 months.
We're in every major
store that matters.
It's gonna light
the world on fire.
Well, Dave, hang on a sec.
I'm not real good with
people completely ignoring me.
You came out here and you said,
believe me, I'm an operator.
I bought in it right away.
I saw the passion.
And at the very end,
when I make you the exact offer
you're looking for,
you throw over
a better offer to mark?
I'm out.
The main reason is--
is getting $60,000
for a strategic investor.
Don't waste your breath on me.
You're not strategically
thinking, my friend.
Your hypersensitive
to the equity you're losing...
Yeah.
And you completely ignore
an offer
that doesn't cost you anything.
Why don't you counter me
with less of a royalty?
I do not want to give up
money when I need it the most.
Horrible negotiation.
I hope mark does do
what I think he's gonna do
to you--screw you.
Mark, if you can get down
to my negotiating range,
what's the difference?
This is one bottle of wine
for you.
Don't lose sight of
a couple percent here.
Let's do this.
Don't lose sight
of your opportunity.
Dave, why don't you get on
your knees and start groveling?
I'm making a pitch.
I'm making
an impassioned plea.
Mark, let's do this.
I understand it's only 2%,
especially since
it's $60,000.
But the flip side is,
that if we do our job right,
that 2% is gonna be worth
a lot of money,
which is why
you're fighting for it.
(exhales deeply)
um, my dad, he's--
he packs all the bottles.
Um, I'd like to give him
a quick phone call,
if you guys don't mind,
and talk about this.
I'm not going anywhere.
So... All right.
Don't change anything
while I'm gone, okay?
(laughs)
mark, I don't understand
why he's so caught up
on the extra 1 or 2%.
Because he knows
what it's gonna be worth.
He's greedy.
So Robert came in
for $60,000 at--at 5%,
it's exactly what I wanted,
but then mark came in
at a little bit higher,
basically $60,000 for 8%.
Which values the company
at $750,000.
Um, but I just think that
he's a better strategic partner.
So I'm gonna try
to talk him down or something.
I tried it once.
I'm gonna try again.
But I think he may be
the right guy to go with.
(man) Okay,
but just remember that
that price, I think,
is extremely low.
And you know what?
Don't be afraid
to walk away
from the deal, Dave.
Are you planning on meeting him
in the middle or holding steady?
No, I'm gonna hold Steady.
Then you should be thanking us
for all dropping out.
I am.
♪♪♪
So, Dave,
you talk to your dad?
Yeah.
What are you gonna do?
Mark, I've thought long
and hard about it.
You're the right guy to partner
with in this business.
I'm very concerned about
equity, as I should be, right?
This is my baby, I've built it
from the ground up.
I understand.
I've been there.
Here's what I wanna do.
Help me a little bit.
Can we meet in the middle?
7%. That's a great deal.
What is wrong with you?
Mark, let's meet in the middle.
I'm a reasonable guy.
Two lids, one dream.
Let's do it.
Come on, mark. Come on.
He's greedier
than you are.
I have never seen such Greed.
Unbelievable.
Mark, I know you're there.
It feels so good
to say Yes.
Just say it, man.
What are you going to do,
Mr. Cuban?
I look at it
the other way around. Right?
A $1.2 million valuation.
2% of that's $24,000.
You're not valuing
my contribution.
Just bringing it
to the mavericks,
you couldn't buy that
for $24,000.
That's why I'm sticking
to my guns.
Dave, think about it.
All right. Let's do it. Let's do
it, man. What do you say?
(Barbara) Oh, thank God.
Deal! Done and done.
Congratulations, man.
You're gonna be great.
Two lids, one dream.
Two lids,
one dream, baby.
All right.
Thanks, bill. Great job.
Dangerous Play.
Dangerous play.
Wow.
Whoo!
He's a greedy pig. I love him.
(laughs)
I'm a lean, mean,
clean bottle machine.
Oh, knock it off.
Oh, as corny as can be.
Yes, sir!
I took a huge Gamble trying
to negotiate with mark,
but I wanted to push him
to the end.
Every percent of clean bottle
means a lot to me.
But at the end of the day,
I got a great deal.
♪♪♪
Last season,we saw Jason and Michael
strike a dealwith Robert herjavec
for their innovativespeaker company Origaudio.
Let's make magic
happen, Robert.
All right.
That's great, guys.
♪♪♪
(motor whirring)
Since appearing
on "Shark tank,"
Origaudio is growing
out of control.
We've relocated
from chicago
to our brand new Offices
in Sunny Southern California.
We have nine employees now.
Our products are
in such high demand,
by the time they come in
to the United States,
we're shipping them out
the next day.
(forklift beeps)
We moved all of our inventory
out of Mike's garage
and into a huge warehouse
that ships and fulfills
all of our orders.
We have huge
international Deals
from distributors
who saw us on "Shark tank."
You can find our origaudio
speakers in 4,000 stores
here in the U.S. And in
38 countries around the world.
Our business
has increased 300%.
And our sales
are over $2 million.
We just had our company valuated
at over $4 million.
Our experience on "Shark tank"
Was priceless.
We are now
the small speaker company
That's making a lot of Noise.
♪♪♪
Hi. I'm Nancy Bush.
And I'm Sue kruskopf.
Our company is
my wonderful life,
and we're here today
to ask you for $100,000
for 10% of the company.
So how about a show of hands--
how many of us are gonna die?
But how many of us
tell our friends and family
exactly what we would want
for our funeral?
My wonderful life
is a free Web site
where you can plan
and personalize your own funeral
so you get the celebration
you want.
And it takes a huge burden
off of your family.
We came up with the idea
after I lost my husband
about five years ago.
And even though he was sick
for about a year,
when the time came,
we still really didn't know
what he wanted.
We ended up pulling together
a really memorable,
really celebratory, uh,
party in his honor
at one of his favorite bars.
I had people come up to me
afterwards, saying,
"how do I make sure I can have
a celebration like that?"
it was really awesome.
And had he had our site,
it would have been
so much easier
for him to let us know
what he wanted.
When Nancy and I went
online, we found--
god, there really aren't any
options to do that out there.
Further Research showed
that 75% of baby boomers,
like us, really want something
far more celebratory--
we don't want the funeral
our parents had.
The death rate is gonna double
over the next 30 years.
I mean, what a huge
business opportunity that is.
So let us show you
how it works.
Okay, Well, Kevin, since you are
Mr. Wonderful, of course...
that's so True.
It is so True.
So of course,
we have to talk
about the wonderful life
of Kevin O'Leary.
You basically go online,
you fill out an online book,
and inside are all the options
that you can have
in terms of, you know, where do
you want your funeral to be?
What kind of wine
do you want to have?
Cabernet? I mean--
and--and really,
do you want to prepay
for your funeral?
I mean, that's something
that we know
you would want to do
for Sure.
Then what you do is
you designate up to six people--
could be your fellow sharks--
who are going to
carry out your wishes.
They just Click on a Link,
and they get a summary
of everything you would have
wanted for your funeral.
It's an $11 billion
industry...
$11 Billion.
And we're gonna
lead the way.
So who's gonna join us?
I love the DEAD guy Business.
(Sue and Nancy Laugh)
For the very reasons
you've identified--
Everybody's gonna bite it.
So what's the plan
that you make money?
We're very, very excited
because we have just partnered
with one of the largest
insurance companies
in the country,
and we have developed,
uh, a product called
the my wonderful life plan.
And so people can set aside
any amount of money
to prepay
for their funeral.
It's basically like buying
an insurance policy.
So when you die,
your loved ones--
all they have to do
is print out the summary.
On the summary, it says,
"Kevin's paid for his funeral.
Here's where you can
access the money."
So does the money go to you?
We make a commission
on every sale.
Oh, I see.
So we're making about 5%
on every sale.
What's a typical sale?
If you were to put away $5,000
for your funeral,
we would make $250 on that.
Who does the money come from?
The money comes from
the insurance company,
and they hold the money,
and that money continues
to earn interest for them.
How many users
do you have today?
We have 7,000 today.
How long has the site been up?
It's been up three years.
What did you gross?
We actually have not
made any money to date.
The problem I see
with your business model
is a very small fraction
of the people
actually preplan
their funeral.
Well, is that True?
Yeah, it's True.
That is actually not True.
That is not True.
What--what percentage?
If you look at, um,
just funeral planning
in general,
25% of the people over 50
prepay in some--
but they do it with
the individual funeral home.
A lot of us don't wanna
go through a funeral home.
You can go through
a funeral home
to be cremated or whatever,
but you may just want
to have a great party,
and that money is put aside
to have a party
at your favorite place.
I get what you guys
are trying to do.
Have you signed exclusive deals
with These insurance companies?
It's not an exclusive deal.
That's a killer to me.
(Kevin) Nothing proprietary
about this.
Why can't I just set up
uncle Kevin's snuff city?
What's even worse--
I can come in and go
to those same companies
and say, you know what?
I'll take a little bit less,
but I want an exclusive.
And then all of a sudden,
you're stuck.
This was an INTERESTING idea
based on an emotional moment
in your life, Nancy.
I understand that.
But as a business plan,
I see all kinds of holes in it.
Nothing proprietary about it.
You're captured by
an insurance company,
hard to acquire customers,
competing with
the funeral homes themselves
that have no interest
in giving you any business.
We have surveyed
the members that we do have,
and 40% of them say
they want to prepay.
So this isn't something that,
you know, we're just throwing
out there in, you know,
hopes that people will...
no one saying there's not
a potential business,
the problem is,
you haven't taken
a lot of the basic business
steps to protect yourself.
In all my business,
I always ask myself,
if I was trying to kick
my own ass, what would I do?
And those are the things
you haven't done yet.
Well, and that's why we're here.
I'm out.
We have 7,000 members
right now, and bas--
they're paying you nothing.
Did any of
the 7,000 people die?
Um, yes.
And what prevented them
from paying at that point?
We didn't have that available
at that point.
I think that I'll probably be
dead before I see my money back.
I'm out.
But here's the thing, guys.
If 40%
of our 7,000 members right now
wanted to put aside--
Let's just say $5,000--
that--that immediately
generates $700,000.
But you haven't tested that.
If you had tested that model,
you've already accumulated
so many dollars in commissions,
you would have a whole
different presentation here.
But you're really here
too early.
I'm out.
If your investment
is $100,000,
we'll get 25,000
new members,
based on a $4-per-member
Acquisition.
Sue, how do you know that?
Because We've tested it.
We--we invested
some of our own money
to see how much it would cost
to get a member.
But you didn't monetize them.
And you didn't
protect it, either.
Sue, I don't think
you've even, uh,
gotten out of
the starting gate.
There's no business.
I'm out.
Kevin, come on.
Kevin.
Oh, you've gotta be kidding.
It really sucked.
The most interesting
part of your pitch
is you said,
"Everybody's gonna be dead."
(singsongy) I'm listening.
And then you don't tell me how
I make any money from them.
Come up with a plan that
every guy that dies,
I make some money.
Then I'm in.
Aw, Goll.
That's it.
Well, I don't wanna plan
your funeral, Kevin.
(laughter)
I'm never gonna die.
I'm a vampire.
I'm out.
Aw. All right.
Thanks for your time.
All right.
Good luck, Ladies.
Ugh. I hated it.
♪♪♪
Next up is Michael Levin,
whose business can help anyonebecome a published author.
My name is Michael Levin
and my company
is businessghost.
I'm asking for $200,000
in exchange for 10%
of the company.
I'm a writer.
In fact, I've done
more than 100 books.
My work has been made into
tv shows and movies,
and has appeared
on "The New York times"
Best seller list.
But chances are
you've never heard of me.
That's because
I'm a ghostwriter.
I help people tell their Stories
from behind the scenes.
My clients include some of
the top C.E.O.S in America,
major sports figures,
top broadcasters,
and celebrities.
Just about everybody
has a dream
of becoming
a published author.
At businessghost,
we make that dream come True.
Here's how it works.
You come to us
with the need for a story.
Our team will organize it,
write it,
design it, publish it,
and market it--
one-stop shopping.
I can see businessghost
becoming the leading provider
of ghostwritten books
in the United States.
But I can only make that happen
with your expertise
and your capital.
Who's interested?
I understand the business model
of one ghostwriter.
Right.
I'm trying to understand,
how does that work
on a larger scale?
Well,
that's a great question.
The first name of
the company is "Business."
Most of our clients are
businesspeople,
are entrepreneurs,
and there are tens of millions
of businesses
in the United States.
Basically, we have
a writing team of eight writers.
The writers do
the interviewing.
We have a chief creative OFFICER
Who oversees their work.
It's my job
to bring in the work.
How much
do you charge for that?
We charge anywhere
between $35,000
and $75,000.
Does that include
a run of the book?
Yes. That includes the--
the--the printing of the books
so that they've got
actual physical books.
And how many copies
of the hardcover book?
You get 50 to 100 copies
of the book.
So how do you acquire
new customers?
Is it all referral business?
It's mostly referral business
up to this point, Yes.
We're averaging about
two books a month right now.
Honestly, we're doing about
$650,000 to $700,000 gross
this year.
Mike, you've achieved
what every writer never gets--
profitability.
But I don't know if this
is a leveragable business.
I don't know
if you can turn it
into a $5 million-a-year
business.
You're basically selling
vanity printing.
In other words, I'm a guy,
I want a book,
I can't get a U.S. Publisher
to pick me up,
I come to you,
you bang out 100 copies,
costs me 35 grand.
Yeah. Yeah, I-I cringe
a tiny bit on the inside
when I hear the word
"Vanity."
But yes, we are making
a marketing tool
disguised as a book.
We tell our clients,
your income stream
is not gonna be revenue
derived from the sale
of the book.
Use the book to build
your business.
Why aren't you interested
in the people
who wanna write about
their dog and their friend,
and the story they had
growing up?
It may not necessarily
be business-related.
Why are you staying
away from that?
Because then you open yourself
up to a much bigger market.
Right.
Right. Daymond--the first thing
I wanna say, daymond,
is that I-I loved your book,
"display of power."
I love the way
you suck up.
You're next. Anyway...
(laughter)
You're good...
you like that?
(singsongy) as a schmoozer.
(laughs)
Where was I? Daymond--
why aren't you opening up
to the masses?
You know, it's--
it's about quality.
It's about the integrity
of the quality.
I'm putting my name
on every book.
Not everybody in the country
can afford a book.
I cannot do a book at $10,000
and make money on it.
Mike, I've--I've heard
your business model.
I understand it.
But to scale this business,
to take it public,
to make it liquid,
for me to get back
my $200,000,
regardless of what percentage
of the business I take,
I see as
a very difficult challenge.
I don't see how I'm going
to make any money here.
I'm out.
Well, in that case,
I'm not gonna
schmooze you anymore.
(sharks laugh)
Oh, I like this guy.
You know, the question
about scalability
is incredibly important.
I True--I truly believe that
with somebody other than moi
running the company...
to do what?
To do what?
To give
the business direction.
I'm the classic example
of the entrepreneur
who has taken something
as far as he can
and has reached
knucklehead Status.
Michael, you can't offload
the responsibility
of coming up
with the right strategy.
That's where
it falls apart for me.
The best salesman
in your company,
the guy who's responsible
for a strategy, has to be you.
I'm out.
Okay.
I-I appreciate that.
Um, you know,
I-I still think
that just about anybody
on the planet
could do a better job
of running my business
then I--well, that's--that--
that's too self-deprecating.
I wanna address that
if I could.
Please.
I've found, in the many
years of experience I have,
the minute someone Running
any business, large or small,
starts talking about
getting a C.E.O.,
It's code for "I'm tired
of my business,
"and what should really
be happening is
I should be going
into a different business."
So I'm out.
I think if I invested
into this business,
getting my money back
will end up being
a mystery book.
I'm out.
Well--well stated.
Punch to the Gut.
Okay.
Mark, it's, uh,
just the two of us.
There's a lot that I like
about your business.
And literally--you, right?
You're a hustler.
Where I have
significant problems
is you didn't really address
the specific changes
in your industry.
There's a real
fundamental question as to
whether or not people will even
publish Books going forward.
That's exactly right.
I think the book itself
as a tool of
disseminating information,
sadly, is all but disappearing
in society.
And ironically,
in an era when books
are Harder and Harder
to make money on,
a business owner who has
one of our books
is gonna stand out
even more from the crowd
because there's something
so wonderfully old-school
and significant
about a book.
And that's--that's--
that's my pitch.
That is the linchpin of
the future of your business?
That's correct.
To me, that has
the future potential
of investing in
a weightlifting snowman.
A weightlifting snowman?
You think about that.
Now if this was 1995,
I probably would have invested.
I'm out.
All right. Thank you, Mike.
Thank you, all, so much.
Good luck, Mike.
What's with
a weightlifting snowman?
Think about it, Barbara.
(laughter)
♪♪♪
I did not get a deal today.
It is very disappointing.
Um, it's gonna be tough
to tell my kids.
But the real thing is that
I'm very, very passionate
about what I do.
Businessghost will go forward,
and I'll keep on
telling people stories
because That's--that's
what's in my heart to do.
♪♪♪
(indistinct conversations)
I'm alashe Nelson.
I'm from miami, Florida,
and the name of my company
is ez vip.
We've all had that night
where you go out,
you go to a club,
you're stuck outside,
you can't get in,
and it can be
really embarrassing.
I had enough
of all the uncertainty
that come with going out,
and that's exactly when
I created ez Vip.
Everything good?
It's good.
I've been able to hire staff,
get in new office space,
and we're turning a profit.
Right now, we're only in miami,
but I've proven
my business works.
My company's on the verge
of something big,
and more important
than the money,
I wanna align myself
with the sharks
for all they can bring
to the Table.
♪♪♪
Hi. My name
is alashe Nelson.
I'm from miami, Florida,
and I'm founder and C.E.O.
Of ez vip.
I'm seeking $150,000
for a 15% stake in my company.
Say you're visiting
miami tonight.
You heard about
this great event going on.
It's the talk of the town.
So you decide
to take a couple friends
and a couple clients out
to entertain them
and show them a good time.
Only problem is,
when you arrive at this event,
there's over
700 people outside,
and now your whole night
is in jeopardy
and you're embarrassed in front
of your friends and clients
because you just brought them
to an event
that you can't even
get them into.
This scenario happens to people
every night of the week.
I thought to myself,
there has to be a better way.
I envisioned a Web site
where people could come,
view the best events
in any city,
and prepurchase
their night out.
What expedia does
for airlines
or what opentable
does for restaurants--
we do that for night life.
Once you find the exact
events you want to attend,
you can prepurchase
admission tickets,
uh, bottle service.
I mean, you can even choose
the exact V.I.P. Table
inside of a venue
that you want to attend.
Once you select everything,
you make your purchase.
That's it, you're done.
And it doesn't matter if you
do it a day in advance
or three months in advance.
You can always opt to have
one of our ez vip reps
meet you in the front,
walk you in,
and give you the treatment
you deserve.
We launched in miami,
which we all know
is one of the biggest
nightlife markets in the world,
and right away,
it was a hit.
So I just have one question
for everyone--
who wants to be V.I.P.
With me?
How much money
you making on this?
Just in miami,
we did $90,000 net.
Really?
Gross, we did
a little over $250,000.
Impressive.
Just in miami alone.
What are the levels of
these type of venues?
Are they high-end?
Luxury?
All high-end. All high-end.
With us, it's about having
the top venues in any place.
So when you come to ez vip,
you can close your eyes
and point to a venue,
and you'll wanna be there
for one reason or another.
If you didn't wanna be there,
they wouldn't be on our site.
Last time I went to miami,
it cost me $130,000
in Champagne.
I could have called you,
and you would have
saved me some money?
I'm so glad
you brought that up.
(laughs)
Some people came to our site.
They were from out of town--
well, actually,
out of the country.
I think, like, russia
or something like that.
They prepurchased their night
to an event, right?
Two months in advance.
I think they spent, like,
$1,000 on a table.
Fast forward
Two months later.
A-a big game happened.
These guys won and they went out
to celebrate that night, okay?
I happen to have been
there that night
that my Buddy, uh...
(laughs)
Won the nba championship.
I was there. I was there.
I was there.
Once he went in there,
the table minimums went to
$20,000, $30,000, $40,000.
Are you saying that night,
somebody actually
prebooked with you,
that person was locked in,
and the Promoter didn't say,
"you can't come in now.
I'm getting $10,000"?
Yes. That's exactly
what I'm saying.
And once a sale goes through,
that sale is final.
And all of the prices
That's set on the site
are set beforehand.
I somewhat don't believe it,
because they may say, "I'm not
giving this to your people.
"I can get $5,000 easily here
and you're gonna try to book out
10 of my--or 20 of my tables"?
how it works is this--
say if the venue has
30 tables,
and they're willing
to presell Ten or five.
You come to the site, you're
gonna get a list of events--
only the top events--
and from there you select
the exact table you want,
a picture of that table
comes up,
you see this table has
a $700 minimum. It seats 6.
And the advantage to the owner
is that you're selling it
ahead of time,
so they know they got
cash coming in.
Is it only in miami?
Right now,
we launched in Miami.
Now we just secured contracts
in L.A., vegas, and new York.
How do you even know I'm the guy
with the table waiting?
The bouncer
has Everyone's name
who prepurchased something
that night.
Listen, daymond is out
every night
with At least five Girls
on his arms.
No, I-I got two Puppies.
He lives that life, I'm at home
reading a novel every Night.
Yeah.
So this is a life that
I can't even relate to.
Yeah.
And for that reason alone,
I'm out.
Our whole thing
is access and Convenience.
That's what we push
to our clients.
The reason why I started
with Nightclubs and nightlife
in General is because That's
the market I understand.
Let me tell you, um,
where I'm at on this deal.
It's a very interesting, um,
business you've built.
I admire your initiative here.
But I'm sitting at home
with Barbara
with the dog by the fireplace.
Oh, I'm gonna get sick.
I'm out.
I like the idea, right?
Al, I like you.
You know, I see the game.
I see what you're trying to do.
Yeah.
But it's just hard
for me to connect
with this type of business.
And that's why
you have a partner.
You wouldn't have
to worry about that.
Well, but I do, right?
Because things I do...
Yeah.
I like to be
successful at.
Yeah.
And I like to kick ass at.
And I just don't know if I'll
be able to connect enough
and provide enough time
to really get you
to the next level.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
I love the idea,
but I hate to admit it,
but I'm a pretty old,
Boring guy.
I don't really
hang out at nightclubs.
I'd love to be in on this
if you can get daymond involved.
I'll give you the $75,000
if you can get
the other $75,000 from daymond.
For what percentage?
Well, I'm not there yet,
Kevin.
Now... I've always wanted
to go clubbing with a croatian.
Always.
(laughter)
Uh...
daymond, you don't go out
'till midnight.
I'm asleep by 11:00.
And here is my opportunity.
Whoo-whoo!
right?
(laughs)
I want 45%.
(Kevin) Whoa.
Robert understands
technology,
so I would partner up
with Robert.
So, Robert, if you're okay
with $150,000 for 45%...
I'm in.
$75,000 from daymond,
$75,000 from me,
and I promise I will never
be seen in the nightclubs.
We want you there.
For 45%.
Um, so that's an offer?
I... I have to
turn that offer down.
Wow.
Wow, you didn't even
think about it.
(daymond) Yeah.
(Barbara) Wow.
This isn't
a $1-million company.
This isn't a $10 million,
$50 million,
this is a $100,
$500 million company.
So for me to sell 45--
not today. Not today.
For me to sell--but I
understand where it's going.
If you would have offered me
that 12 months ago...
make a counter.
Maybe we would have had
a conversation.
Make a counter.
(Barbara) Impressive.
18.
18 what?
18%.
Crazy.
(laughs)
18%.
I love your confidence.
See, that's almost
an insult.
It's no emotions.
It's just...
sometimes in negotiations,
when we're so far apart...
mm-hmm.
It doesn't make any sense.
I don't wanna waste
your time.
No. It's no waste of time.
We're talking about money.
It's never a waste of time.
We're just talking.
I love that.
So all right. All right.
All right. Check this out.
I'll--I'll sweeten
it a little bit.
Okay.
I work with
a lot of artists.
I work with Pitbull.
He's one of the biggest
artists in the world.
Ooh!
I'm going back to the 45,
but I'll throw in
an artist like pitbull.
That's a big deal.
A face
behind the brand.
For 45%.
That's what this is missing.
Here's what I'll do.
I'll go halves with you,
but no Robert.
I hate being screwed
on these deals.
It's nothing personal, Robert.
No, it is personal, cuban.
Okay, it is.
It is, but I don't care.
(laughs)
I know you don't care because
you're that kind of guy.
I mean, you sit there and you
screw us all in the very end.
I get it.
♪♪♪
Alashe has one dealon the table
from daymond and Robert.
Mark has decidedto come back in
and attempt to kick Robertout of the deal.
I hate being screwed
on these deals.
It's nothing personal, Robert.
No, it is personal, cuban.
Okay, it is.
It is, but I don't care.
(laughs)
I know you don't care because
you're that kind of guy.
I mean, you sit there and you
screw us all in the very end.
I get it.
So, al, um,
I've decided that....
We're gonna run over Robert
like a scurvy dog...
(laughs)
and cuban and I will offer you
for $150,000 at 45%,
and I will bring
an a-list artist as a face,
and I will take that
out of my share.
(inhales and exhales deeply)
and I will be there
to help you with the tech.
See what kind of partners
they are?
They'll throw you
under the bus
without thinking about it,
my friend.
They're sharks.
What do you expect? (laughs)
(Kevin) Just to keep it
interesting in the tank
and add a little
je ne sais quoi...
Yeah.
I'm gonna throw out
an offer--
$150,000 for 25%.
And, you know,
I'll come and dance with you
once in a while.
(sharks laughs)
Are you serious, Kevin?
I'm dead serious.
That changes a lot, guys.
Friend,
here's what I'll do.
Okay.
I'll go in with Kevin.
And let me tell you something.
Pitbull is a great artist,
but there's a lot
of artists out there.
Mm-hmm.
We can get that same deal.
I have absolutely
no doubt in my mind.
You know what? James Taylor,
Paul Simon I know
would love this deal.
Don't even bother with that.
This is just noise.
So I'll partner with Robert,
I'll give you $150,000,
$75,000 each, for 25%.
And we'll provide
technical services...
mm-hmm.
And financial depth
when you need it.
You make it happen in L.A.,
in vegas, in new York,
we're there.
And that artist comes out
of your percentage?
Yes. Yes.
Comes out of
our percentage.
It's the same deal.
You know what? It is not
the same deal, Kevin.
It's not the same deal
'cause we're only getting 25%.
Just remember this--
retaining 55%
of a watermelon
is a whole lot better
than 75% of a grape.
Don't sell yourself Short.
Who was it that when they walked
into one of your clubs,
the price of the tables
went up 10x?
No, I remember.
But you know what?
You're not selling
to guys like cuban.
Let's be honest.
Guess what? I am not
gonna lose this deal,
so here's what
I'm gonna do--
I'm gonna offer you
the $150,000 for 30%.
So it's a worse deal.
Why would he do that?
He's not stupid. Look at
the business he's built.
(mark)
Because we bring more value.
We bring more value. But I need
an answer from you now.
Right now.
Right now. (laughs)
$150,000, and I will bring
an a-list artist to it.
Okay, look,
I'll keep it interesting.
That's what I love about me.
I just like
to keep it interesting.
$150,000 for 20%.
You just took our percentage
down to 20?
If you don't wanna be
with me, that's okay.
(laughs)
All right.
You know what? I'm in.
$75,000 each of us, 20%.
When you need to have
that right party
at the right club
to get that deal signed...
Yeah.
We're gonna be able
to walk in,
daymond and I,
and help you close the Deal.
That face recognition
you talked about
is gonna help you
close the deal.
Al, that is such noise.
You've proven
a business model.
People that own clubs
aren't there to party.
They're there to make money.
Exactly.
That's what Kevin
and I are offering you.
I'm not a big shot
like cuban.
I'm not arrogant like cuban.
30%. 30%.
Time out. Time out.
Why?
Because--because
you can trust me.
I'm not in the deal, okay?
People who have
the most fun with their business
make the most money.
Ask yourself, who are you
gonna have the most fun with--
These Boring guys...
or Those two guys?
Trust your gut.
Good point. Good point.
You're gonna give up
10% equity for fun?
Trust your gut.
Let me start off
with you guys' offer.
Obviously, for the financial
part, their offer is better,
um, for the Percentages.
30%. 10% Difference.
That's a lot.
You know,
especially as we grow,
and we don't know
what the future holds.
And as from this side,
I love the tech,
I love just
the--the merchant of truth.
I respect it,
I understand it.
But I think what this side
is missing is the branding guy.
So for that...
wait a sec.
I'm gonna have to go here.
Wait a sec.
Let me haul this...
he said "Yes."
He said he went in.
He said he went in!
(Barbara) It's a deal! (laughs)
Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you.
We are gonna party
and have a great time.
Thanks, man.
We did it!
(laughs)
Mmm.
Good decision.
(mark) All right, man.
Congratulations.
Not on my watch!
Daymond, I-I expect that
from cuban, not from you.
Thank you. I'll take that
as a compliment.
When I went out there,
it was--it was a feeding frenzy.
The sharks, uh, identified
with my--my idea,
and I mean, I think
they saw the real value in it.